alle anwesenden hier sind frisch und
negativ getestet und wir diskutieren
hier auf dem stand der hochrechnungen
kurz nach 20 uhr
wohin geht deutschland und mit welcher
regierungskonstellation
darüber wollen rainald becker und ich
diskutieren mit dem
spd-kanzlerkandidaten olaf scholz dem
gemeinsamen kanzler kandidaten von
cdu/csu armin laschet mit der
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen annalena
baerbock dem fdp-parteivorsitzenden
christian lindner mit der
spitzenkandidatin der afg alice weidl
der linken chefin susanne hennig welt so
und den csu parteivorsitzenden markus
söder allen hier an der runde da
momentan ganz herzlich willkommen und
natürlich innen auch liebe zuschauer und
herzlich willkommen auch von mir herr
scholz sie sind ich sag mal vielleicht
der sieger des abends es wird ja immer
noch gezielt genau wissen wir das noch
nicht aber unabhängig davon aus dem
ergebnis was bisher bekannt ist leiten
sie daraus den anspruch für eine
regierungsbildung ab und werfen sie
zuerst an wm bieten sie
sondierungsgespräche
tun ist minister ist das votum der
bürger und bürger sehr eindeutig die
balken bei der spd sind nach oben
gegangen und nach den gegenwärtigen
umfragen sind die spd ergebnisse auch so
dass wir in allen umfragen vorne liegen
das ist eine ermutigende botschaft und
wie ich finde auch ein sehr klarer
auftrag jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass wir
eine gute pragmatische regierung für
deutschland zustande kriegen die sich
mit den wichtigsten zukunftsaufgaben
beschäftigt die wirtschaft mehr respekt
in unserer gesellschaft zu organisieren
wie wir das hinbekommen dass wir die
industrielle modernisierung in
deutschland auf den weg bringen und dass
wir den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten und das wird in den nächsten
tagen und wochen zu klären sein
möglichst schnell übrigens aus meiner
sicht aber wen sie zuerst anrufen wollen
sie nicht verraten ja ich habe ja schon
immer gesagt dass ich finde dass das
große schnittmengen gibt hier zum
beispiel aber es wird ja nicht alleine
reichen deshalb wird es zu dritt sein
müssen und das glaube ich wird sich in
kurzer zeit klären ich jedenfalls glaube
dass es der respekt vor den bürgern und
bürgern gebietet dass wir auch die
endgültige auszählung aller ergebnisse
abwarten und dann wird man klar sehen
aber mein wunsch ist konstruktiv mit
beachtung all der ansatzpunkte die von
unterschiedlichen parteien eingebracht
werden so dass sich jeder und auch das
ganze land in einer regierung
wiederfinden kann erläutert mit einem
verlust zur vergangenen bundestagswahl
von etwa 8 punkten verzeichnet die union
die höchsten verluste des abends das
stimmt es ist auch das schwächste
ergebnis dass cdu und csu bei der
bundestagswahl erzielt haben sie haben
wir da haben schon gesagt sie wollen
trotzdem kanzler werden aber ist das
nicht der situation ein resultat bei dem
ein parteivorsitzender auch an
persönliche konsequenzen denken muss
also erst mal ist das natürlich ein
verlust an stimmen der nicht schön ist
wir haben eine situation erlebt dass zum
ersten mal nach 16 jahren angela merkel
die bundeskanzlerin nicht mehr
angetreten ist also insofern hat niemand
einen amtsbonus bei dieser wahl und das
wahlergebnis ist jetzt so dass sich aus
der mitte des deutschen bundestages eine
neue regierung ergeben muss das hat uns
der wähler aufgetragen es ist keine
partei so stark dass sie das alleine
kann und deshalb wird es jetzt darauf
ankommen aus der mitte des bundestages
so viele gemeinsamkeiten wie möglich zu
finden zwischen einem wahrscheinlich
erstmals dreierbündnis aus drei
politischen partei familien im moment
lägen sie auf nummer zwei in den beiden
umfragen von ard und zdf das kann sich
noch ändern aber wenn sie wirklich auf
zwei landen halten sie dann am anspruch
fest ins kanzleramt einzuziehen und
gleiche frage wie bei olaf scholz in
welcher konstellation welche erwerben
sie heute abend hat er gerade
beschrieben wer bundeskanzler in
deutschland wird muss es schaffen
unterschiedliche fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages zusammen zu
bringen und dann am ende eine mehrheit
zu haben das war in allen 70 jahren der
bundesrepublik so nicht immer weil die
partei die auf 1 war auch die den
kanzler stellt und deshalb ist das jetzt
die große aufgabe der demokratischen
parteien zu sehen wo gibt es die größten
gemeinsamkeiten
ich glaube die zeit die vor uns liegt
braucht als erstes wirtschaftliche
stärke und stabilität
marktwirtschaftliche lösungen sie
braucht einen großen schub in der
verwaltung des landes bei der
digitalisierung und das thema
klimaschutz hat gerade in diesem
jahrzehnt die aufgabe eine ganze
industrie gesellschaft frage herr
laschet die csu hat es ja anders gesehen
sie hat gesagt aus der position zwei
kann man das kanzleramt nicht
beanspruchen ich hab grad die
verfassungslage geschildert und im auge
söder hat heute auch die position der
csu erläutert
insofern ist es doch jetzt eindeutig es
geht ja nicht darum dass man
arithmetisch irgendwie eine mehrheit
zusammen kriegt sagt ich wünsche mir
eine regierung wo auch jeder partner
vorkommt wo auch jeder sichtbar ist
keine regierung allein der kanzler mit
seinen punkten glänzen kann sondern wo
unterschiedliche politische positionen
so zusammengeführt werden dass das auch
eine koalition ist die man gerne macht
das war in der großen koalition am ende
nicht mehr so der fall also das kann ein
bündnis werden was wird nicht
deutschland voran bringt
unterschiedliche richtungen versöhnt und
dazu stehe ich bereit
darum das nochmal klassement sie sitzen
ja mit herrn laschet und dem unions
ergebnis sozusagen in einem boot wenn
sich der zweite platz der es im moment
ist verstetigt und bestätigt leiten sie
daraus einen regierungsanspruch ab also
zum ersten mal ist noch nicht ganz klar
wie das ergebnis wirklich ausgeht sie
haben es vorhin schon angesprochen es
schwankt auch zwischen prozenten und
dann den sitzenden deutschen bundestag
in einigen umfragen bei der ard liegt
die union sogar bei der fraktions zahl
von abgeordneten vorne was auch einen
eigenen führungsanspruch noch mal
zusätzlich wäre aber am ende kommt es
tatsächlich ab wenn die deutschen am
ende dieses regierungsamt an vertrauen
schauen sie es gab ja lange dieses
modell rot rot grün das hat heute schon
eine klatsche bekommen die deutschen
möchten nicht rotor können und dieses
misstrauen gegen rot grün ist indirekt
auch ein misstrauen gegen olaf scholz
denn er hat diese idee favorisiert das
sind glaube ich kein bündnis des gestern
oder rückwärts gewandt sondern eine idee
wirklich wie deutschland stabil bleibt
und wie wir erneuern können und ich
glaube dass wir diesen anspruch gut mit
armin laschet dokumentieren können
vielleicht mit der tp und mit den grünen
zusammen weil ich glaube da ist der
größte wunsch nach veränderung da nach
reform und erneuerung und wir bieten
dann an der richtige partner dafür zu
sein trotzdem die nachfrage muss heute
abend glaube ich auch gestellt werden
bei dem verlust den cdu und csu
eingefahren haben wäre das ergebnis mit
ihnen besser gewesen für ihre partei
waren sie ja der kandidat der herzen
das ist wirklich schnee von gestern und
bringt uns ja auch in dieser schwierigen
situation die welt hätten gar nichts wir
haben die letzten zwei wochen noch mal
wirklich einen tollen schlussspurt
hingelegt und ich muss jetzt einmal ganz
menschlich persönlich sagen ich habe
großen respekt vor allem die lasche denn
in diesem wahlkampf ist ja immer so viel
unernst haft ausgesprochen worden also
auch über lebensläufe über über lacher
über all diese dinge anstatt sich über
die ernsten fragen zu beschäftigen und
nämlich viel wie ich finde unrecht getan
waren und deswegen hat er meinen respekt
und meine unterstützung auch für diese
auseinandersetzung frau werburg gemessen
am ausgangspunkt im april/mai zählen sie
heute abend auch zu den verlierern mit
einem wahrscheinlich doch auch für sie
enttäuschenden stimmenzuwachses gibt den
zuwachs aber sie wollten ja sehr viel
mehr war der anspruch doch zu groß die
erste grüne kanzlerin zu werden und
warum hat es nicht geklappt trotz der
flutkatastrophe trotz des klimawandels
das sind doch eigentlich alles themen
die für sie auf sie heraus liefen ja
offensichtlich haben wir unser grünes
wahlziel was wir ausgegeben hatten eine
führende kraft in diesem land zu sein
nicht erreicht sondern sind weit
darunter geblieben wie enttäuscht sind
sie heute abend ja das kann ich nur
grund zur freude ist das ist ziemlich
klar aber es war absolut richtig die
union herauszufordern deutlich zu machen
wir brauchen in deutschland eine
erneuerung und unserem land demokratie
lebt von alternativen und das hat für
den wahlkampf ja auch eine ganz andere
dynamik gegeben die nächste
bundesregierung die muss eine klima
regierung sein das ist der klare auftrag
nach dieser wahl wir haben unsere
stimmen deutlich deutlich verbessert und
das ist auch der klare auftrag für uns
grüne dass das jetzt in der nächsten
bundesregierung umgesetzt wird und dafür
tragen wir auch die verantwortung dass
jetzt zu tun weil die herausforderung
gehen jetzt ja nicht weg bloß weil das
wahlergebnis vorliegt sondern eine
erneuerung dieses landes ist jetzt das
oberste gut für die nächste deutsche
bundesregierung darüber sprechen wir
gleich noch mal aber ich will sie auch
noch mal fragen zehn prozentpunkte mehr
als auf dem höchststand der umfragen im
april was heißt das jetzt auch für die
machtarithmetik bei den grünen in ihrer
partei ist so bitter das für sie
vielleicht ist ab heute abend robert
habeck die nummer eins bei den grünen ja
wir haben bereits im frühjahr deutlich
gemacht dass wir in die sondierung als
team gehen wir haben eine
kanzlerkandidatin für diesen im
wahlkampf aufgestellt weil wir führende
kraft in diesem land werden wollten
dieses land anführen wollten dass es
nicht gelungen offensichtlich aber wir
haben den klaren wählerinnen und wähler
auftrag für eine neuerung in diesem land
zu sorgen dass werden robert habeck und
ich gemeinsam in diesem sondierung
genauso machen und sie hatten gefragt
was passiert mit blick auch auf den
sommer wir hatten das duell in den
ersten monaten mit der union und die
entscheidende frage war wer wird der
nächste bundesregierung gibt es eine
echte erneuerung und in dem moment in
dem moment wo die spd uns überholt hat
es ist ein wettstreit zwischen den
beiden parteien geworden so bitter für
uns das jetzt ist aber wie gesagt das
was jetzt gemacht werden muss das hat
sich dadurch nicht verändert und das
bedeutet deutschland klimaneutral zu
gestalten
berlin da ein bisschen dazu gewonnen und
sie gelten als königsmacher aber allein
mit der union werden dass gerade schon
wird's ja nicht reichen sie müssen sich
also mit den grünen mit frau werburg
irgendwie arrangieren heißt es diesmal
bei der fdp lieber mit einem ungeliebten
partner regieren als gar nicht regieren
die fdp war und ist bereit verantwortung
zu übernehmen wir regieren auch in ganz
unterschiedlichen formaten in
deutschland beispielsweise in nordrhein
westfalen mit armin laschet in einer
schwarz gelben koalition
es gibt in schleswig-holstein jamaika es
gibt eine ampelkoalition in
rheinland-pfalz und in sachsen anhalt
eine sogenannte deutschland koalition
wir sind auch sehr eigenständig in
diesem wahlkampf gegangen es gab ja
sogar bisweilen kampagnen der union
gegen die fdp wir sind eigenständig in
diesen wahlkampf gegangen und wir gehen
jetzt auch eigenständig aus dieser wahl
heraus wir haben für unsere inhalte
geworben für eine politik der mitte für
den wert der freiheit den gedanken dass
der wohlstand erst erwirtschaftet werden
muss bevor er verteilt werden kann wir
wenden uns gegen verbote und für eine
offenheit für technologie und mit dieser
eigenständigen inhaltlichen positionen
gehen wir in gesprächen das heißt aber
sie reden auch mit olaf scholz und
seiner spd denn die ampel könnte ja die
denkbar stärkste option sein nun ja das
wahlergebnis ist nicht ganz einfach zu
lesen zunächst sehen wir dass die
politischen ränder geschwächt sind und
die politische mitte gestärkt ist wir
sehen dann dass keine der früheren
volksparteien mehr als 75 oder mehr als
25 26 prozent erzielt hat also etwa 75
prozent der deutschen haben die partei
eines nächsten kanzlers nicht gewählt
und deshalb herr becker könnte es ratsam
sein dass die parteien die gegen den
status quo der großen koalition
wahlkampf gemacht haben die aus einer
unterschiedlichen perspektive heraus
diesen status quo überwinden wollten das
also grüne und fdp zuerst miteinander
sprechen um dann all das was danach
kommt zu strukturieren kurze nachfrage
versorgt werden sie dazu bereit
sozusagen zuerst mit der nidda zu
sprechen bevor die großen die wahlsieger
1929 sind werden bereits in den letzten
tagen ja auch deutlich gemacht robert
habeck und ich dass diese logik da ist
einer der alle anderen anruft dass diese
logik dem aufruf den die in unserem land
brauchen nicht gut tut und deswegen ist
es mehr als sinnvoll dass
unterschiedliche parteien jetzt seinen
unterschiedlichen kombinationen
miteinander sprechen gespräch findet ja
jetzt auch schon hier in dieser runde
statt vorher nicht weil so
überraschender weise vertreten sie nun
statt ihrer spitzenkandidatin janine
wissler die linke die partei die linke
in dieser runde sie kämpfen aktuell noch
um den einzug in den bundestag das kann
noch schief gehen um diese zeit hatten
sie die falsche spitzenkandidatin war
sie einfach zu links zu abgehoben von
den wählern nein auf keinen fall missen
und dietmar bartsch am einen
hervorragenden wahlkampf geführt dass
wir in den vergangenen jahren viele
fehler gemacht haben das zeigt auch
dieses ergebnis dass es mit sicherheit
nicht in den letzten wochen entstanden
sondern es ist ein zeitraum in dem wir
uns einen bestimmten themen nicht
entschieden haben wo wir keine klarheit
gezeigt haben und es ist natürlich auch
so dass wir nach 30 jahren opposition im
bundestag sehr schwer darstellen können
dass auch wir bereit sind verantwortung
zu tragen wir tun das in den einzelnen
bundesländern und können das auch bodo
ramelow zeigt insofern ja sie haben
recht für uns ist das kein schöner abend
und es wird ein sehr langer abend werden
ich gehe davon aus dass wir tatsächlich
im deutschen bundestag verbleiben werden
und wir werden die vier jahren natürlich
nutzen um uns weiter zu entwickeln und
ein stärker wiederzukommen frau weiter
bei ihnen ist es eigentlich relativ
einfach keiner will mit ihnen sie haben
stimmen verloren woran liegt das am
internen streit an der schlechten
oppositionsarbeit
wo sehen sie die ursachen
wir sind sehr zufrieden mit dem ergebnis
wir sind zweistellig geblieben
man hat uns ja prognostiziert dass die
afg eine eintagsfliege im bundestag ist
dass man uns nach der ersten legislatur
auch wieder aus dem bundestag hinaus
wirft das haben wir wieder legt wir
können auf eine sehr solide
stammwählerschaft zählen und wir haben
natürlich da sie jetzt gleich den
vergleich gezogen haben zu den wahlen
2017 haben wir natürlich hier einen
sondereffekt den antritt im bundesweiten
der freien wähler den natürlich ganz
klar in unserem fahrwasser gesegelt sind
als auch eine sehr corona kritische
partei die basis und wenn man diese
sondereffekte
bereinigt dann
liegen wir sogar über dem ergebnis von
2017 also wir konnten uns deutlich
verbessern und das zeigt natürlich auch
von unserer sehr guten oppositionsarbeit
und der abend ist ja noch lang wir
schauen was die prognosen noch bringen
werden morgen haben wir dann die
ergebnisse vielleicht auch spät heute
abend und dementsprechend sehen weder
sehr sehr gelassen und auch gut gelaunt
in die nächste legislatur herr scholz
sie streben an die nachfolge von angela
merkel zu übernehmen mit einem so
schwachen wahlergebnis wie noch nie
zuvor ein kanzler in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik erzielt hatte ich will
das aufgreifen was er lindner gesagt hat
man könnte auch sagen mehr als 70
prozent der wählerinnen und wähler haben
sich eben nicht für sie entschieden und
zum ersten mal wird ein kanzler seine
macht mit zwei parteien teilen müssen
wenn es zu dem von ihnen favorisierten
ampel modell kommt grünen und fdp und es
könnte sein dass die beiden kleinen
zusammen genauso groß sind wie sie sind
sie jetzt sozusagen ein während sie dann
ein schwacher koch mit zwei starken
kellnern und mal gerhard schröder zu
aufzugreifen
mit diesen koch und kellner vergleichen
habe ich es noch nie so richtig gehabt
das finde ich falsch ich glaube es geht
immer darum dass man auf augenhöhe mit
den anderen zusammenarbeitet und dazu
gehört auch dass man
versucht dinge so zusammen zu binden
dass es im ergebnis dazu führt dass
unser land ein fortschritt macht also es
geht nicht nur um geschäftsführer
logischen von parteien sondern sich ganz
um das land das ist eine andere
machtarithmetik als zb bei rot grün wo
die erst mit der sehr viel größer war
als die crew das ist anders klar wobei
ich gerne mit dem bemerken glauben darf
manchmal wirkte die aktuelle koalition
auch wie eine drei parteien koalition
das kann ich nicht verleugnen ist sie
auch sagt herr söder also stelle ich
auch und insofern habe ich schon ein
bisschen übung aber unabhängig von
dieser frage wenn wir uns umschauen in
unseren nachbarländern finden wie viele
länder in die das längst und zwar sehr
lange realität ist insofern finde ich
wird es schon gehen es geht um eine
regierung die vernünftige zielsetzung
hat und sich auch miteinander vornimmt
gut zu regieren durchaus mit einer
perspektive dass man sagt wenn wir dann
antreten zusammen wollen wir auch
gemeinsam wieder gewählt werden das kann
nicht so sein wie ich das wahrgenommen
haben in der schwarz gelben koalition
die mal kurz
regiert hatte machen wir noch ein
bisschen analyse sozusagen des
wahlergebnisses herr scholz rot grün rot
ist stand jetzt keine option mehr sie
haben immer daran festgehalten das ist
auch eine variante für die spd sein
könnte war das ein fehler eine solche
koalition sich offen zu halten haben sie
damit nicht am ende den wahlkampf der
union angefeuert ich glaube ich nicht
wir haben ja auch im übrigen nicht das
getan sollen wir gesagt wir wollen dass
die bürgerinnen bürger entscheiden wie
die parteien und mit welcher stärke
sehen den deutschen bundestag gehen und
haben all diese versuchungen wird dem
nicht nach der vor der wahl schon die
regierung zu bilden und das ist ja
eigentlich kein großer respekt vor den
wählern und wähler wenn man so vorgeht
es muss schon so sein das wir sehen wie
wollen die das haben und die haben ja
viel geändert die spd ist stärker
geworden als bei den letzten wahlen sie
ist aber auch noch viel stärker geworden
als in den umfragen vor einigen wochen
und monaten und insofern glaube ich ist
hier schon ein sehr sehr eindeutiges
votum will das mal so sagen es gibt ein
paar parteien die hier am tisch sitzen
die haben zuwächse erzielt die spd einen
sehr großen die grünen die fdp und
andere haben keine zuwächse erzielt auch
das ist eine botschaft
verlassen
olaf scholz will kanzler werden sie
wollen es auch jetzt reden wir mal
darüber wenn sie es nicht werden und sie
nummer zwei sind was was bleibt dann was
raten sie ihrer partei erneuerung in der
opposition
juniorpartner der spd und dann die frage
muss auch heute abend glaube ich mal
gestellt werden könnten sie dann
parteivorsitzender bleiben
wir haben noch nicht mal alle ergebnisse
wir warten noch darauf wir haben heute
doch erkannt kanzler wird nur jemand der
eine mehrheit im deutschen bundestag hat
und deshalb würde ich doch und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch die erwartung der
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
erst jetzt mal sehen welche richtung
soll das land nehme nur welche themen
reden wäre das ist doch jetzt die
kernfrage und nicht die
selbstbeschäftigung was wird aus dem
wenn dieses oder jenes eintritt wir
werden das dann in der union besprechen
wenn der zeitpunkt da ist jetzt ist der
zeitpunkt da zu sehen wie kriegen wir
für dieses land eine regierung in dieser
lage in der wir stehen mitten in europa
wir haben ja viel zu wenig wie ich finde
auch in den tri allen hier haben wir die
am letzten donnerstag mal gesprochen
über europa und internationale politik
ganz europa schaut im moment was wird
aus deutschland und eine lage das am
wahlabend nicht klar war wer wird
kanzler hat deutschland in der form auch
ganz selten nur gehabt aber gerade
deshalb stellt sich ja die frage es gab
schon mal die situation da ging dann nur
noch eine option die option wäre
rechnerisch auch möglich kann die cdu
nummer zwei
jetzt haben wir nach meiner einschätzung
ist jeder der meinung dass diese große
koalition auch der arbeitsstil dieser
großen koalition nicht zukunftsträchtig
ist egal wer nun 1 oder 2 wir brauchen
hier einen echten neuanfang der auch
nicht so erzwungen wird die große
koalition war ja auch bei der spd muss
man ja an erkennen nicht dass wunsch
konzept 2018 wir haben ja jamaika
versucht es hat dann aus vielen gründen
nicht funktioniert und dann hat man
irgendwie nur einmal große koalition
gemacht und das was jetzt beginnt
muss auch den reiz haben dass man sagt
ja da kommen unterschiedliche
gesellschaftliche strömungen zusammen da
entsteht was das vielleicht wirklich
diesem land einen neuen schub geben kann
auch mit den dingen die man lösen
wirtschaft und ökologie noch stärker
versöhnen als bisher wenn das alles
nicht geleert wir sind für die
opposition nicht aus zumal uns gelingen
denken herr becker und nicht als nicht
gelingen ich bin immer ein mensch der
uns gelingen denkt und der will dass
jetzt etwas gutes für deutschland
entsteht er wird uns gelingen denken sie
sich ja auch gerne zünglein an der waage
ist die liberale traumrolle heute abend
gibt es aber vielleicht zwei zünglein
sie haben ja bisher eher auf ein bündnis
mit der union gesetzt und den grünen was
muss olaf scholz in bieten damit ist
auch eine ampelkoalition werden kann und
muss vielleicht ein bisschen konkreter
zu machen frau baerbock sagte eben es
muss eine klima koalition werden ist das
ein stichwort mit dem sie leben könnten
oder fängt hier dazu ist schon an jetzt
haben sie einerseits nach den scholz
gefragt und andererseits wer wodka so
frau berbalk zitiert
ich habe die parteiprogramme alle
gelesen und wenn man das tut stellt man
fest dass die größten inhaltlichen
übereinstimmungen zwischen den
unionsparteien und der fdp sind das habe
ich vor der wahl gesagt und das will ich
nach der wahl auch ausdrücklich
wiederholen für uns sind die ideen von
steuererhöhungen oder aufweichen der
schuldenbremse auch nach der wahl noch
keine akzeptablen ideen ich glaube alle
nächste regierung wird
sehr viel ökologischer sein man muss ja
das ergebnis der grünen zur kenntnis
nehmen sehr viele menschen in unserem
land die sich eine höhere ökologische
sensibilität der politik wünschen das
wird in einer nächsten regierung
notwendig seien auch umzusetzen und zum
anderen wenn ich sehe welche gutes
ergebnis die fdp erzielt hat mit unserem
einsatz für technologieoffenheit für die
bürgerlichen freiheitsrechte für eine
stärkung unseres wirtschaftlichen
aufschwungs so ist meine erwartung dass
sich auch dieser gedanke in einer
nächsten koalition wieder findet aber
eins er frei wenn sie den gedanken noch
kurz gestatten 1 ist an diesem abend
dort glaube ich eine gute nachricht die
uns verbindet anders als in anderen
europäischen
demokratien wird in deutschland einer
regierungsbildung eine koalitionsbildung
aus dem demokratischen zentrum der
politik möglich sein ränder werden dafür
nicht benötigt eine gute nachricht weil
all diejenigen in europa und darüber
hinaus die sorgen hatten um die
stabilität deutschlands können jetzt
erkennen deutschland wird in jedem fall
stabil bleiben setzt gesagt handelt man
sich sagen im prinzip bin ich auch mit
spd und grünen koalitionsfähig
regieren in rheinland-pfalz aber
trotzdem wäre ihre schlussfolgerung
falsch wenn sie daraus schließen würden
dass das eine präferierte option ist uns
geht es um inhalte
es war die frage eben von herrn becker
auch vor vier jahren hätten wir ja ein
jamaika-bündnis machen können war damals
war die idee von union und grünen dass
die fdp nur einen schwarz grünen
koalitionsvertrag unterschreiben sollten
unsere inhalt haben keine rolle gespielt
und das muss und wird sich jetzt ändern
und ich kann nur sagen ich würde mich
wenn es zu jamaika gesprächen kommt ich
würde mich immer dafür einsetzen dass
union und fdp mit den grünen fairer
umgehen als union und grünen das 2017
mit der fdp gab sie an linda dann fragen
wir doch die grünen frau berg sie haben
wie die fdp im grunde zwei möglichkeiten
mitzuregieren wäre denn ein bündnis mit
cdu und fdp ihrer basis überhaupt
vermittelbar gibt es dafür eine mehrheit
in ihrer partei bei uns gibt es eine
deutliche mehrheit und das ist unser
auftrag und das ist auch der auftrag
dieses wahlabends dass die nächste
bundesregierung die weichen dafür
stellen muss dass dieses land in den
nächsten zwei jahrzehnten klimaneutral
wird und das ist dann nicht nur ein
ressort muss dafür verantwortlich ist
sondern das bedeutet mit blick auf die
industrie ja die diesen falschen
eingeschlagen hat jetzt alle leitplanken
so zu setzen damit deutschland diesen
vater klimaneutralität nicht nur geht
sondern dafür sorgt die in den letzten
jahrhundert dass der wohlstand dieses
landes geht dadurch gesichert wird das
zieht sich durch durch das
verkehrsministerium durch das
landwirtschaftsministerium und das ist
die große aufgabe der nächsten
bundesregierung und deswegen ist mein
auftrag meine verantwortung als grüne
parteivorsitzende gemeinsam mit robert
habeck das zu erörtern wo können wir
dieser großen verantwortung die wir
nicht nur als partei sondern als land in
der welt haben gerecht werden und da
muss man mit allen akteuren dann
gemeinsam das heißt das buch macht es ja
keinen sinn zu sagen wir machen neuen
koalitionsvertrag es geht nicht um den
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner sondern es
geht jetzt wirklich in diesem
historischen moment die weichen für die
zukunft zu stellen und uns am see viele
junge menschen im land gewählt da sind
wir ganz vorne führende kraft gewesen
und das ist nicht nur eine frage von
klimaschutz die frage ist eine
generationsgerechtigkeit frage und der
muss man verantwortungsvoll gerecht
werden herr söder wir reden gleich
nochmal über inhalte auch an sie will
ich die frage stellen was eigentlich so
das hauptthema dieser koalition sein
könnte die sie formen wollen aber
nochmal zur analyse die csu hat unter
ihrer führung bei den landtagswahlen
schlecht abgeschnitten sie rutscht auch
heute abend noch einmal tiefer höher als
der bundesdurchschnitt der union aber
doch ein ergebnis mit dem sie sicher
nicht zufrieden sind tragen sie dafür
auch persönlich verantwortung haben sie
zu lange gegen armin laschet gekämpft
stadt für ihn wir haben bei der letzten
europawahl das beste ergebnis aller
parteien erzählt in deutschland mit 40
prozent werden bei der kommunalwahl in
bayern große erfolge zieht in dem wir
städte wie nürnberg und augsburg geholt
haben aber jetzt sagen bei unterstellter
absturz habe was sie sagen immer man
muss sie die ergebnisse immer im kontext
sehen ja wir haben unser ergebnis ist
nicht ausreichend das ist absolut so das
hängt unter anderem auch ein bisschen es
wurde von sogar freigesprochen im freien
wählern den stärkeren punkte gemacht
haben was ich sehr bedauere übrigens
weil diese vielleicht 23 prozente der
freien wähler könnten dann
möglicherweise ein echtes bürgerliches
bündnis gefährden deswegen war das ein
schwerer fehler der freien wähler dies
zu tun aber zurück haben uns gefällt das
ergebnis nicht wir haben aber glaube ich
kann man sagen haben in den letzten
wochen noch mal deutlich
tempo gemacht gemeinsam und ich glaube
der parteitag der csu auch die
abschlussveranstaltung das war echter
rückenwind an das kann ich sagen wir
tragen immer alle gemeinsam die
verantwortung das ist bei solchen
wahlergebnis inhalt nicht schnell zu
gewesen wir tragen immer alle gemeinsam
die verantwortung und ich glaube dass
mit unserem schlussspurt wir noch vieles
nach vorne gebracht haben und jetzt muss
man halt 1 1 aus diesem ergebnis auch
eine regierung bilden ich meine ich
finde schon dass das nach diesen 16
jahren ist schon ein bedürfnis gibt
viele menschen nach veränderung
herausforderungen die da sind und die
müssen wir angehen und die muss man
kraftvoll angenehmes mitführung angehen
die kann man nicht nur so verwalten
jetzt bisschen wie urlaub schulzes quasi
mit einer hochwertigen notariellen
funktion versehen da muss auch bisschen
kraft trainer sein da muss ideen da muss
auch zukunftsvisionen dahinter sein und
ich glaube die substanz ist bei uns mit
abstand am stärksten und es wird klar
jetzt ein bisschen taktiert jeder sagt
verweist nochmals sein programm aber
alle werden aus der komfortzone gehen
müssen alle müssen mal aus diesen aus
diesen parteien raus und dann auf den
tisch legen was ist möglich was ist
eigentlich hatte sie dann persönlich um
diese kraft auf die schiene zu bringen
auch nach berlin wechseln so
ungewöhnlich das wäre für den
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten einigen
ich bin hier da und und wieder auch gern
in der wunde hier und freue mich wenn
sie auch öfters ist ich glaube dass ja
wenn sie jetzt diese konstellation in
ihr so sehen wird ja zunächst mal gerade
am anfang eine große verantwortung den
koalitionsausschuss kommen also nach
meiner erfahrung der letzten jahre war
das auch so dass der koalitionsausschuss
eine zentrale bedeutung hat und da bin
ich als parteivorsitzender dann glaube
ich da und denke mal so dass wir
zusammen die beiden parteivorsitzenden
da eine große rolle spielen ich glaube
sogar historisch gesehen bin ich eine
der freundlicheren
csu-vorsitzenden zumindest was unsere
gemeinsame ist verhältnis mit der cdu
biete jetzt freihändig also heute abend
sie müssen nicht taktieren bei ihnen
geht es eigentlich um die existenz in
den letzten wahlergebnissen auch heute
abend sind sie dauerhaft hinter auch in
ihren hochburgen im osten
dauerhaft hinter der afd was machen sie
falsch warum laufen die wähler davon und
setzen sie möglicherweise auf die falt
auf die falschen themen wie sahra
wagenknecht ihnen ja vorgeworfen hat
also zunächst natürlich
das was wir verloren haben dass wir mal
am heutigen abend nicht gut machen und
hoffen natürlich dass wir im deutschen
bundestag bleiben diejenigen die
tatsächlich von ihren sind ja diejenigen
die die sogenannte mitte koalition die
jetzt hier schon von verschiedenen
seiten geschmiedet wird eben vergisst
und das sind die millionen menschen die
in diesem land nach 16 jahren unions
regierung tatsächlich gar nicht genug
geld haben um leben zu können die bürger
engten wohnverhältnissen dem die sich
keinen urlaub leisten können die 40
prozent und mehr ihres einkommens für
die miete zahlen es sind die
rentnerinnen und rentner die auf eine
rentenerhöhung angewiesen sind es sind
diejenigen die einen höheren mindestlohn
brauchen um überhaupt ein einkommen zu
haben dann was armut fest ist und all
das versteht diese mitte nicht alte ihr
problem das aber auch - mein eindruck
heute an schulden aber das sind ja dann
nicht die die sie wählen weil sonst
würden sie nicht um die fünf prozent
hürde kämpfen na ja ich würde sagen es
gibt einen deutlichen widerspruch in dem
das wir aus meiner sicht durchaus die
richtige frage nicht die soziale frage
in diesem land stellenweise sie
erheblich stellt auch was den sozialen
zusammenhang unsere gesellschaft angeht
und dem widerspruch dass uns menschen
nicht vertrauen dass tatsächlich
durchsetzen können da haben sie recht
ich habe ja auch zu beginn gesagt dass
wir in der vergangenheit auch fehler
gemacht haben dass werden uns anschauen
aber in einem bin ich mir sicher dass es
bei der nächsten regierung nicht darum
geht das an die nach spaß beim regierung
hat zur sorge es geht darum auch
diejenigen in den blick zu nehmen die
tatsächlich in arm und in diesem land
nehmen und das sind millionen und nicht
nur wenige vorweisen sie haben film
behauptet sie seien glücklich an diesem
abend und mit diesem wahlergebnis dabei
ist ihre partei mehr denn je zerrissen
zwischen völkischer radikalopposition
und einem flügel der mitregieren will
nach ihrer niederlage heute abend das
ist es ist eine nieder frage es gibt
keine option mitzuregieren und sie haben
stimmen verloren müssen sie sich nicht
langsam mal entscheiden zwischen
erneuten unterdrücken
die unterscheidung muss man nicht
treffen und ich möchte das auch
zurückweisen was hier gerade gesagt
haben völkisch national das gibt es bei
uns nicht und das weiss ich ganz weit
von mir
dass ich viel interessanter finde auch
während des wahlkampfes und auch heute
abend das beispielsweise die grünen die
hier eine klima regierung anstreben
hierzu der mitte zu der politischen
mitte in deutschland stilisiert wird
also wenn wir jetzt mittlerweile schon
so weit die grünen als koalitionspartner
überhaupt zu denken dann kann ich
einfach nur sagen gute nacht
industriestandort bundesrepublik
deutschland also ich denke mal in vier
jahren wenn wir uns hier wieder sehen
werden die verhältnisse ganz ganz anders
liegen
bis heute abend haben sie alle hier am
tisch als wahlkämpfer ihre inhaltlichen
positionen vorgetragen jetzt müssen aus
versprechungen kompromisse werden
deshalb fragen wir jetzt wo sind sie
bereit abstriche zu machen um
koalitionen bilden zu können damit das
ganze nicht wieder so ein quälender
prozess wird wie
2017 beginnen wollen wir mit den
parteien auf die es jetzt ankommt herr
lindner es geht jetzt um gemeinsamkeiten
mit den grünen habe jetzt schon mal
angedeutet gleich ob in einer ampel oder
in einer jamaika-koalition sie werden
gebraucht und diese regierung zu bilden
was tut ihnen denn mehr weh die
solardach pflicht oder der verzicht auf
steuersenkungen der das bedeuten könnte
oder lässt sich aktive klimapolitik am
ende doch mit entlastung für den
steuerzahler kombinieren
er frei also ich fühle mich überfordert
jetzt koalitionsgespräche in einer
fernseh live sendung an zu streng aber
die leute und das ja dass in welche
richtung sie sich bewegen ja wo wir
nicht mehr das amtliche endergebnis
haben aber ich spiele gerne vorschlag
machen wir haben ja vor der wahl bereits
ins gespräch gebracht ein super
abschreibungs programm wo private anlage
investitionen die dem klimaschutz und
der digitalisierung dienen schnell
steuerlich wirksam würden das hätte
einen doppelten effekt zum einen treiben
wir die modernisierung unserer
wirtschaft und des mittelstandes voran
und zum anderen kann es gelingen die
jetzt gegenwärtig beklagenswert geringe
wachstumsraten unseres landes zu erhöhen
ich glaube dass das ein angebot ist das
wenn man die unterschiedlichen dinge
miteinander verbinden will auf den tisch
gehört herr linder will keine
koalitionsverhandlungen zumindest nicht
hier und jetzt für eine frau weil ich
versuche jetzt mal bei ihnen wären sie
denn bereit die schuldenbremse zu
akzeptieren um beispielsweise union und
fdp entgegen zu kommen wir akzeptieren
die schuldengrenze nicht möglich steht
ja in unserer verfassung wir haben
deutlich gemacht dass wenn man die
großen zukunftsaufgaben unseres landes
angehen will dann kann man nicht einfach
davon reden irgendwie muss man überall
das internet verlegt werden und
irgendwie brauchen wir auch
klimaneutralität sondern wir brauchen
massive investitionen in unserem land
wir haben investitionsrückstau in den
kommunen von über 140 milliarden euro
und deswegen ist unser vorschlag die
schuldenbremse zu erweitern durch eine
investitions regel damit wir diese
investition in die zukunft des landes
auch wirklich stemmen können nur weil
das jetzt klingt jetzt ein bisschen wie
und basia ich meine politik ist kein
basar natürlich muss man in einer
demokratie immer kompromisse machen
sonst hätte hier einer 50 prozent
mehrheit und könnte sein gesamtes
programm umsetzen so funktioniert das
aber nicht die entscheidende frage ist
doch was sind die großen zukunftsthemen
dieses landes klimaschutz soziale
gerechtigkeit kinder und jugendliche
endlich in den mittelpunkt zu stellen
und eine europäische verantwortung und
diese ziele die müssen in der nächsten
bundesregierung angegangen werden und
welche mittel ist dahin braucht das ist
ja gut wenn jetzt zum beispiel eine
andere partei sagt wir wissen auch statt
einer solarpflicht machen wir ein solar
sonder ausschreibungs programm es geht
ja nicht um die mittel sondern es geht
um das ziel
was am ende erreicht werden muss und
wenn wir diese ziele erreichen das ist
die verantwortung die demokratische
parteien tragen jetzt deutschland zu
erneuern und darüber müssen jetzt
ernsthaft gespräche geführt werden da
gerade bei der klimafrage kennt uns die
zeit massiv davon belastet dass wir
jetzt so ein mini regierungsprogramm
also wir führen keine
koalitionsverhandlungen aber an dem was
frau berbalk jetzt skizziert hat in
wenigen worten gibt es da etwas wo sie
sagen kommt mit mir nicht in frage
was wir aber gerade geschrieben hat
das finde ich sehr hilfreich dass man
einfach mal sagt was wollen wir denn
jetzt eigentlich erreichen wenn wir
wollen dass die solarenergie ausgebaut
wird hatten wir das angebot das wir für
alle flächen ein kreditprogramm der kfw
machen wo man zu null zinsen
photovoltaik machen muss die fdp hat
gerade einen vorschlag gemacht wo sie
anreize setzen will dass das vorangehen
und die grünen halten für jedes neue
einfamilienhaus oder für jedes haus eine
pflicht das sind zwei unterschiedliche
wege das ziel ist aber das gleiche und
das ist ja jetzt die aufgabe vor der wir
stehen dass wir erst jetzt vielleicht
mal wirklich in sachlichkeit definieren
was muss passieren in den nächsten
jahren frau burke hat gesagt sie braucht
massive investitionen um die klimaziele
zu erreichen sie wollen steuersenkungen
ist das vor allem ein wir
natürlich brauchen wir massive
investitionen ist doch klar steht bei
uns im wahlprogramm drin wir glauben nur
dass man zu mehr steuereinnahmen kommt
indem man jetzt nach der pandemie einen
fesseln wegnimmt für die die investieren
sollen da anreize geben und wir glauben
dass wenn die wirtschaft wieder
anspringt wir mehr steuereinnahmen haben
als wenn sie jetzt ausgerechnet die
bestrafen
ja die ja investieren sollen das war
denn die sense im wahlkampf dass
investitionen erforderlich sind steht
völlig außer frage deshalb glaube ich
dass jetzt
der zeitpunkt da ist
die soziale frage da würde ich übrigens
ihnen widersprechen dass
diese koalition oder diese beiden
unionsparteien nicht für soziale frage
stehen viele arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer wählen die union gerade
auch wegen der sozialen frage und wenn
wir arbeitslosigkeit niedrig haben und
neue arbeitsplätze schaffen ist das die
größte antwort auf die soziale frage als
vieles von dem was die linke vor trägt
also das ziel muss jetzt sein zu
wirtschaftlichem wachstum zu kommen
dieses muss ökologisch dieses muss
nachhaltig sein und die investitionen
die erforderlich sind sind zurecht
beschrieben war so er stolz jetzt kommen
noch mal zu ihnen steuererhöhungen sind
sabotage am aufschwung hat christian
lindner gesagt und steuersenkungen
gefordert wenn sie ihn ins boot in eine
koalition holen wollen wo machen sie
dann zugeständnisse
hier wird nicht verhandelt hat herr
lindner gesagt hat frau baerbock gesagt
das ist auch richtig so das würde sich
nicht gehören wir müssen jetzt mit
unseren jeweiligen parteien sprechen
über das was demnächst ansteht und dann
finde ich nur geht es darum dass wir
immer zwei kriterien beachten das erste
es muss sich in einer regierung jeder
jede partei mit ihren wählerinnen und
wählern wiederfinden denn da haben ja
welche die stimme abgegeben weil sie
bestimmte vorstellungen damit verbunden
haben und gleichzeitig muss es so sein
dass ein realer fortschritt für unser
land zustande kommt und dass die
erwartungshaltung die damit verbunden
sind auch erfüllt werden das geht schon
darum dass wir hier wirklich etwas
voranbringen für deutschland ich habe
das gesagt die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes ist die
wichtigste aufgabe die wir jetzt
zustande bringen müssen sonst haben wir
in zehn 20 30 jahren keine guten
arbeitsplätze mehr und schauen dem
wohlstand auf anderen kontinenten
traurig zu das kann ich nicht
akzeptieren dass das keine das immer ein
wichtiger punkt sein und ich finde dass
es auch ganz real darum geht dass wir
den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten für mich ist das etwas wo wir
werden das tri politik reden müssen und
wie wir das möglich machen können es
geht im übrigen über um überwiegend
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen wie
wir in dieser runde und anderenorts auch
schon diskutiert haben da braucht es
also gar kein öffentliches geld zu aller
erst und das muss möglich gemacht werden
dass diese dinge zustande kommen aber es
muss die große bewegung ermöglicht
werden das wäre ein modernes
industrieland das gleichzeitig
klimaschutz betreibt werden und für mich
spielt natürlich die frage des respekts
in unserer gesellschaft eine große rolle
es kann nicht so sein dass ein teil der
bürger nur bürger das geführt da kommt
eine gute zukunft aber sie haben nichts
davon und sie sind nicht dabei wir
müssen das was jetzt in der kroner krise
auch an anerkennung für die
lebensleistung und berufliche leistungen
vieler bürgern und bürger sichtbar
geworden ist das müssen wir auch nach
der korona deshalb aufrecht damit
verliert die große bewegung ist das eine
aber die leute wollen natürlich wissen
mit welcher regierung sie möglicherweise
mehr geld in der tasche haben mit
welcher regierung es ihnen besser geht
ja die vorschläge die ich dazu habe habe
ich ja jetzt ein paar wochen monate
immer vorgetragen das genauso
funktionieren kann und jetzt muss
miteinander gesprochen werden das ist
doch richtig und ich finde was ist das
verwunderliche das verwunderliche ist
nicht dass drei parteien eine regierung
bilden werden müssen sondern das was ich
gut hinkriegen will ist dass es schnell
geht schnell geht
es gehören inhalte dazu auch wenn wir
nicht verhandeln wollen ein jamaika
bündnis das auf ihrer seite sozusagen
dann angestrebt wird zusammen mit den
grünen könnte vor der frage stehen ende
des verbrennungsmotors
sehen sie da spielräume die grünen
wollen keine neuzulassung mehr ab 2030
werde die internationale automobil
ausstellung gesehen hat jetzt bei uns in
münchen stattgefunden hat merkt wie weit
die industrie an der stelle schon ist
ich kann mir vorstellen 2030 halte ich
für nicht machbar dass es gibt zu viele
brüche aber 2035 das ende eines fossilen
verbrennungsmotors ist durchaus denkbar
wären wir noch synthetische kraftstoffe
so dass da gäbe es sicherlich
möglichkeiten allerdings müssen wir dazu
auch enorm voran kommen mit technologie
mit elektromobilität bei einer die
meisten elektro ladepunkte in
deutschland von allen bundesländern wir
bräuchten tatsächlich große wasserstoff
initiative noch dazu und vor allem auch
die förderung synthetischer kraftstoffe
das glaube ich was dabei entscheiden ist
man darf nicht über irgendwelche verbote
reden oder zieldaten sondern muss auch
die technologie fordern bringen also ich
glaube dass entscheidens ist das ist
auch der unterschied vom ansatz her zu
unseren ökologischen ideen dass wir
nicht nur ausschließlich auf ein
gesetzliches verbot von etwas schauen
sondern auf angebot auf andere
veränderungen aber ich glaube schon dass
man da viel erreichen könnt also ich hab
verband waren sich 40 der
klimaneutralität als ziel ausgebe
investieren allein in bayern nur für ein
bundesland eine milliarde euro und da
gibt es viele die in die wir ökologische
ökonomische leistungsfähigkeit
zusammenbringen und das scheint mir ganz
entscheidend und wenn ich das noch sein
darf indem wir auch das gesamte land
mitnehmen bei dieser frage es reicht
nicht die sozusagen die städtischen
eliten aber mit zunehmender noch die
ländliche räume nun bei uns zum beispiel
auch ganz wichtig dass wir für steigende
energiepreise einen ausgleich finden zum
beispiel durch eine erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale
vorher gewählte erste analysen der
wählerwanderung sagen sie haben viele
stimmen an die spd verloren wird es da
nicht langsam zeit ihre positionen
beispielsweise zur nato zu den usa mal
grundsätzlich zu überdenken vielleicht
sogar über bord zu werfen na vielleicht
sollten wir alle unsere haltung
gegenüber der nato und der außen und
sicherheitspolitik überdenken
afghanistan hat gezeigt was das
sogenannte nation building macht was
internistische interventionistische
eingriffe der bundeswehr beziehungsweise
der nato von bring mir nicht gar nichts
und ich glaube schon breiten macht
gerade einen besseren job als hier in
deutschland tun wenn ich darüber
nachzudenken wie wir zur entspannungs
politikum wie wir ein bündnis bilden
können was friedenspolitik tatsächlich
in den mittelpunkt stellt obwohl es am
abrüstung geht wo es um
entwicklungszusammenarbeit geht aber
nicht um weitere konfrontationen und
insofern die wählerwanderung zur spd
erklärt sich ziemlich deutlich die
polarisierung zwischen den beiden
kanzlerkandidaten nach scheint und stolz
und da auch meine erfahrung als straßen
wahlkämpferin ist sehr eindeutig dass
die menschen rot und grün wollten
deswegen olaf scholz gewählt haben das
wäre natürlich aus unserer sicht besser
gewesen hätten sich für die linke
entschieden aber dennoch ist es
natürlich aus der polarisierung sehr
deutlich zu erklären vorbei sie sind
nicht mehr stärkste oppositionsfraktion
sie werden nicht direkt hinter dem
bundeskanzler wer auch immer es wird
sprechen sie haben auch wichtige
ausschüsse verloren den
haushaltsausschuss zum beispiel wie
werden sie darauf reagieren das ist
jetzt im deutschen bundestag für sie
schwieriger wird
also es geht nicht schwieriger also
grundsätzlich ist es so dass der
haushaltsausschuss in der tat der
stärksten oppositionskraft zufällt das
sind wir vier jahre lang gewesen
die stärkste oppositionsfraktion diesen
status werden wir in der tat verlieren
eben auch weil sich das parteiengefüge
durch die durch die wahlergebnisse
verschieben wird ganz klar wir werden
weiter machen wie bisher mit einer
konstruktiven guten oppositionsarbeit
schauen sie wir haben als afd das
instrumentarium der namentlichen
abstimmungen haben wir sehr stark
genutzt das in jedem wahlkreis die
abgeordneten getestet geprüft werden
konnten von den wählern vor ort wie sie
in elementaren fragen abgestimmt haben
das wäre ohne die afd gar nicht möglich
gewesen ich glaube ich muss auch nicht
ich muss auch nicht
weiter denn es ist schon wahr liebe frau
baerbock wir haben sehr viele
namentlichen abstimmungen eben auch
beantragt und ich glaube auch dass es
letztendlich muss es einfach so sagen
der cdu csu auf die füße gefallen ist
wie wir jetzt heute abend auch sehen
nach 16 jahren kanzlerschaft merkel weiß
die bundesrepublik heute abend
eigentlich nur dass ihre regierungszeit
zu ende ist wer mit wem regieren wird
und wie der weg dorthin aussehen ist
auch jetzt drei stunden nach schließung
der wahllokale
völlig offen deshalb jetzt unsere
schlussrunde zum weiteren vorgehen und
zum zeitplan dabei kommt es
möglicherweise ja auch sie an herr
scholz gehen sie eigentlich davon aus
dass es eine siebzehnte
neujahrsansprache von angela merkel
geben wird wird das wieder so lange
dauern wie 2017 oder bescheren sie uns
zu weihnachten oder zum jahreswechsel
neue region mein ehrgeiz ist dass wir
schneller hinkriegen
merkel diese ansprache nicht nochmal
halten muss konzept genauer sagen was
haben sie sich vorgenommen wie lange
darf das dauern ich finde ein genaues
datum zu nennen wäre absurd aber es muss
schon so sein dass ich dass wir alles
dafür tun dass wir vor weihnachten
fertig sind ein bisschen vorher wer auch
noch gut und das geht auch wenn man
konstruktiv miteinander spricht und
nicht letztendlich die sachen laufen
lässt es geht ja auch darum politische
führung zu zeigen und zu erkennen wo
mögliche kompromisse geschlossen werden
können die nicht nur auf dem papier
funktionieren sondern auch in der
wirklichkeit unseres landes darum geht's
doch herr laschet sie haben den anspruch
unterstrichen dass auch sie kanzler
werden wollen die viel zeit geben sie
sich selber um zu einer tragfähigen
regierungskonstellation zukommen
unterscheiden zwischen sondierungen und
echten koalitionsgesprächen wie lange
werden die sondierungen brauchen wie
lange wird es dauern bis das land
ungefähr war es ein wirklich weiß in
welche richtung es geht mindestens
formal könnte es länger dauern weil die
lage heute abend so kompliziert ist ich
würde mir wünschen dass wir schneller
sind und einen ganz anderen stil wählen
als bei den letzten malen sondierung
hieß wochenlang in der parlamentarischen
gesellschaft an einzelnen formulierungen
ringen um dann am ende zu irgendeinem
ergebnis zu kommen und dann erst
koalitionsverhandlungen zu beginnen ich
finde dafür haben wir nicht die zeit und
wir haben bei den ganzen letzten wahlen
erlebt dass das thema das die
wahlperiode am ende geprägt hat nicht im
koalitionsvertrag stand 217 haben wir
nicht über pandemien geredet und wir
haben fast zwei jahre inzwischen in
anspruch genommen 213 hat niemand über
eine weltweite flüchtlingskrise geredet
und es war das dominierende thema der
vorletzten wahlperiode und deshalb kommt
darauf an ob ich das in meinem land und
in der regierung die ich geleitet habe
gesehen
trauen sich die akteure zu dass sie wenn
solche krisen aufkommen da gemeinsam
agieren dass ultras gerade an das kann
man in gesprächen sehr schnell bei den
grundfragen klären ich würde mir schön
dass wir das schnell hinkriegen
deutschland hat die präsidentschaft der
g 7 im nächsten jahr ein ganz wichtiges
forum der großen industrienationen der
welt und wenn die themen hier alle
beschrieben wurden da eine rolle spielen
sollen muss die neue regierung sehr
zeitnah ins amt kommen und deshalb würde
ich mir wünschen dass wir das schnell
hinkriegen das heißt auch vor
weihnachten ja überfall vor weihnachten
frau bärbel wir wissen ja heute dass es
mit ihrem einzug ins kanzleramt wohl
nichts wird aber jetzt geht es ja darum
mit wem reden die grünen wie ist der
prozess welchen prozess haben sie davor
werden sie erste parallel verhandeln und
danach ihre basis entscheiden lassen
oder lassen sie die basis gleich
entscheiden mit wem überhaupt
sondierungsgespräche geführt wird da es
um die sache geht kann man ja vorher
entscheiden bevor überhaupt gesprochen
wurde miteinander dass wir ja falsch
herum aber ich meine das war jetzt ein
bisschen erhält was er gesagt hat wir
müssen mal gucken welche krisen kommen
die große krise und zugleich die große
chance die wir alle kennen ist die
klimakrise und das ist das leitthema der
nächsten bundesregierung und das ist die
basis für uns für jegliche gespräche und
der auftrag der wählerinnen und wähler
ist an dieser stelle auch wenn wir nicht
ganz zufrieden sind über unser ergebnis
auch sehr klar dafür braucht es grüne in
dieser bundesregierung hat der abend
heute hier auch sehr sehr dort das heißt
um da möglichst viel zu erreichen
verhandeln sie auch unter umständen sehr
lange
und lassen sich lange handlungs
verhandlungen sind ja kein selbstzweck
sondern auftrag der wählerinnen und
wähler ist und das erwarten die menschen
doch zu recht in unserem land auch nach
den letzten jahren acht jahren große
koalition endlich besser regiert zu
werden und deswegen ist doch der
anspruch die aufgaben unserer zeit
anzugehen und den gerecht zu werden und
ein regierungsprogramm zu formulieren
was die erneuerung unseres landes
endlich angeht das ist jedenfalls die
verantwortung die ich für uns als
demokratische parteien sehen sind oder
sie haben uns ja eben schon mal ein
bisschen rein gucken lassen wie das
laufen könnte und haben angekündigt dass
es möglicherweise zunächst mal gespräche
gibt zwischen den kleineren parteien wie
stellen sie sich das weitere vorgehen
wir uns als bürgerinnen und bürger
vorstellen dass sozusagen verlotterter
scholz dann parallel verhandeln und sie
gehen montag zu ihm und dienstags zu
jenem und das ganze wird dann 14 tage
drei wochen dauern darauf habe ich noch
keine antwort herr frei denn wir können
ja nur von unserer seite ein angebot
machen und
andere überlegen wie sie ihre gremien
beteiligen welche prioritäten sie setzen
welche gesprächspartner sie suchen also
ich kann von unserer seite ein angebot
machen das erste angebot ist ich bin wie
alle hier der auffassung wir sollten
schnell zu einer regierungsbildung
kommen armin laschet hat zurecht auf die
g7 präsidentschaft hingewiesen wir haben
dringenden handlungsbedarf in der
wirtschaft aus der klimagesetzgebung
dieses landes ergibt sich auch in dieser
frage ein unmittelbarer handlungsbedarf
und europa wartet darauf dass
deutschland einer regierung bekommt zum
ich habe erfahrungen gemacht 2017 mit
armin laschet war es möglich innerhalb
von vier wochen eine regierung zu bilden
in berlin war es von innerhalb von vier
wochen noch nicht einmal möglich
koalitionsgespräche aufzunehmen sondern
es blieb bei den sondierungen meine
schlussfolgerung daraus ist wenn man
sondiert dann sollten all die wichtigen
punkte direkt auf den tisch sollte nicht
im detail gearbeitet werden sondern sehr
schnell von entscheidern geschaut werden
wo kommt zusammen was ist dieser seite
wichtig war es einer anderen seite wie
ich das wird schon ein bonus
parallelverhandlungen und dann habe ich
noch ich sagen dass dritte an bei wochen
starten sie das dritte angebot nochmal
ein erstes angebot war schnell das
zweite angebot wahr dass man direkt bei
sondierungen die wesentlichen punkte
bespricht und sich nicht beschleicht und
das dritte angebot ist von unserer seite
grüne müssen entscheiden ob sie es
annehmen wollen ich hab robert habeck
heute in dieser weise allerdings in
medien auch schon wahrgenommen das
vielleicht grüne und fdp die ja die
größte polarisierung hatten die größten
inhaltlichen unterschiede waren dass
diese beiden zuerst miteinander sprechen
und schauen wo es gemeinsam grund geben
könnte machen sie damit vielleicht kurze
antwort darauf ist das ein angebot wo
sie sagen ich komme zur internet das
hatte ich ja zu beginn dieser sendung
schon gesagt dass es nicht so sein kann
in den letzten malen dass die
wahlergebnisse auch nicht her bisher
aber noch gar kein wahlsieger
festgestellt und vor allem gibt es jetzt
keine partei gesagt ich habe doppelt so
viel wie alle anderen sondern das klar
ist dass gespräche auch vorab mit
anderen geführt werden damit das
wahlergebnis was jetzt hier deutlich
geworden ist auch entsprechend der
wählerinnen und wähler umgesetzt wird
die g7 präsidentschaft mag ja ein grund
für eine schnelle regierungsbildung
seien aber mal ganz unabhängig davon
müssen sie nicht mit blick auf die
landtagswahlen in bayern in zwei jahren
und um ihre machtoptionen zu erhalten
alles dransetzen dass sie in der
regierung sind dass die csu an einer
regierung beteiligt sind es kommt weder
auf g7 allein noch auf die bayerische
landtagswahl zwei spannende gegenpole zu
setzen sondern es kommt darauf an dass
unser land gut regiert wird und die
herausforderungen sind groß und ich
glaube nicht dass wir unendlich lange
zeit haben und wir müssen uns an einigen
stellen einfach auch trauen schritte
voran zu gehen und zwar nicht so kleine
trippelschritte wieder die kleinsten
gemeinsamen kompromisse zu machen endlos
zu feilen sollte sich einer großen
koalition auch erlebt und immer noch
eine hintertür zu finden sondern schon
ein paar sehr wichtige grundlegende
entscheidungen für unser land zu treffen
und deswegen kommt es am ende darauf an
ob
jetzt gar nicht so sehr das einzelne
thema bearbeitet wird sondern gemeinsame
philosophie und verständnis entwickelt
was in diesem land notwendig ist das das
entscheidende und wenn ich jetzt mal von
meiner sicht sage wenn ich an frau bekam
habe ich denke an den christian lindner
armin laschet aber auch wir sind jetzt
auch zu teilen gemeinsame generation
nicht so weit auseinander kann da
wirklich was vor land bringen man könnte
auch eine grundlegende erneuerung fürs
land voranbringen und nicht wieder
sozusagen in den klassischen
schützengräben stecken bleiben ich bin
dafür dass wir unser land gut regieren
das ist das einzige prioritäre ziel für
die menschen in deutschland haben mit
verlaub so rosig ist ihr ergebnis ja
nicht und eine csu die in einer
regierung beteiligt ist hat es doch
sicher leichter als eine csu die in der
opposition ist ja also wir müssen etwas
für die menschen erreichen klar wir
wollen regieren wir wollen regieren
freudigen wollen so nicht nur ihr
wiedereinzug in den bundestag steht auf
der kippe sie haben heute auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern in berlin
deutlich verloren grund zu ende
forschung besteht jetzt die gefahr dass
die linke als politische kraft in
deutschland untergeht nein das glaube
ich nicht also die landtagswahlen in
mecklenburg vorpommern sind ja sehr von
der stärke von manuela schwesig geprägt
also ich fast 40 prozent ganz knapp an
der absoluten mehrheit das ist ja
durchaus schon lange also seit langer
zeit mal wieder ein novum in der
bundesrepublik was berlin angeht da
haben wir auch eine ganz besondere
konstellation auch da gibt es keinen
amtsinhaber der noch mal angetreten ist
also auch da wenn ich sagen da schauen
wir mal was der abend noch so bringt
auch da stehen die endergebnisse noch
nicht fest ansonsten würde ich mal sagen
keiner hier am tisch von den regierenden
hat irgendeine idee wie sie eigentlich
zusammenfinden wollen das sind viele
worte um nichts aber was darunter liegt
sind ja den großen unterschiede und eins
ist fakt annalena baerbock hat doch
gesagt wenn wir in unsere infrastruktur
investieren wollen sei es bildung sei es
gesundheit das verkehrswesen muss meinen
die steuern bei den vermögenden
tatsächlich auch erhöhen damit wir
tatsächlich als staat diese leistung
erfüllen können und das alles
beantworten sie nicht und deswegen bin
ich gespannt waren sie in einer
regierungsbildung kommen wollen frau
beide die afg hat heute mit ihnen als
spitzenkandidatin ja sagen wir mal nicht
gewonnen eigentlich ein bisschen
verloren vielleicht schaffen sie eine
kurze antwort auf die frage bleiben sie
fraktionschefin können sie nach dem
ergebnis an der fraktionsspitze bleiben
ich hab ja eben schon gesagt dass
bereinigt um die sondereffekte der
freien wähler und der basis wir sogar
über dem ergebnis von 2 17 liegen so und
das entscheiden
also die
antwort auf ihre frage ist recht einfach
also das entscheiden erst mal unsere
abgeordneten in der fraktion wir haben
fraktions konstituierung am mittwoch
sagen geht oder ob sie nicht und dann
wird gewählt und ja ich meine ich bin ja
fraktionsvorsitzender vier jahre lang
sehr erfolgreich auch gewesen und tino
keller hat einen hervorragenden
wahlkampf gemacht und
dementsprechend stellen wir uns am
mittwoch auch zur wahl aber dass willen
sein wort haben natürlich die
abgeordneten vielen dank und
unsere schluss fragen gehen jetzt an die
beiden die auch nach dem heutigen abend
weiter um das kanzleramt streiten ja
spätestens übermorgen bei der
fraktionssitzung müssen sie farbe
bekennen treten sie für das amt des
fraktionschefs der union im bundestag an
sozusagen übergangsweise das wäre doch
die voraussetzung dafür dass der traum
des kanzlers nichts wird und dann
könnten sie oppositionsführer seien also
wir haben morgen erstmal den cdu
vorstand und ich habe die absicht die
gespräche der sondierung zu führen aus
dem amt des cdu parteivorsitzenden und
wie wir die fraktion aufstellen das
entscheiden wir danken und sie haben
heute abend uns gesagt trotz dieses sehr
schlechten ergebnis für die union für
die cdu wollen sie auch
parteivorsitzender bleiben ja wir wollen
die nächste bundesregierung führen
das soll eine bundesregierung sein wo
wirklich alle die da starten hat denen
sie sich geeinigt haben auch mit lust
diese nächsten jahre gestaltet und nicht
dauernd mit verdruss es ist eine eine
aufgabe wozu man den willen aller
braucht und dazu will ich auch
parteivorsitzender bleiben herr scholz
ansehe die frage ähnlich sie wollen
kanzler werden das ist aber noch nicht
sicher heute abend wenn das nichts wird
was wird dann aus ihnen
oppositionsführer fraktionschef der spd
und greifen sie nach dem parteivorsitz
nein ich gerade für nicht nach dem
parteivorsitz läuft mützenich ist ein
großartiger fraktionsvorsitzender und
ich möchte kanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland werden ich habe den umfragen
enormen dass viele bürgerinnen bürger
das auch so sehen dem wahlergebnis
nämlich diese botschaft auch da in dem
ich sie auch und deshalb wird es eine
aufgabe sein das sich jetzt alles dafür
tun dass eine regierung gebildet wird
die den wunsch der wähler und wähler
auch umsetzt es gibt hier viele parteien
die viele stimmen verloren haben wir es
gibt auch einige die haben ganz schön
gewonnen
meine damen und herren das war heute
abend die berliner runde wir bedanken
uns bei unseren gästen hier rings um den
tisch im alten telegrafenamt in berlin
und natürlich bei ihnen für ihr
interesse und jetzt geht es in den
programmen von ard und zdf weiter mit
hochrechnungen und analysen zu dieser
spannenden wahl einen schönen abend aus
berlin
[Musik]
und zurück im zdf wahlstudio nach der
berliner runde bieten wir hier noch
einmal kompakt